so on your second circle hmm I want you
to draw this is a bit tricky I want you
to draw a secant something like this
draw me a secret okay and then that's
actually not my whiteboard marker that's
actually a dent in the whiteboard I want
you to put the center of your circle
onto here okay then I want you to
connect up some radii like so and then
lastly beside this diagram if you have
space draw a little circle because I'm
just going to illustrate for you the
property we're going to prove with this
circle here okay there are tangents draw
me at agit any change it I'll draw this
one yes
here's a tangent now the tangent
intersects with the circle exactly once
what I'd like you to draw is the radius
of the circle to that intersection point
so if the center is he R then the
radiation is going to come down toward
the tangent like so
okay radius tangent the radius of the
tangent are related to each other there
are not just out in random direction
what does the angle look like between
the radius and the tangent what's it
look like
it looks perpendicular doesn't it it
looks like it's a right angle so how we
go about proving this okay well we're
going to use this diagram so here is a
secant it's not a tangent but secant and
tangents are quite closely related
together have a look at this triangle
we've created it here what kind of a
triangle is this triangle it's isosceles
because it has two radii 42 lengths
right so therefore it stands to reason
that if I call this angle up here theta
right I should be able to find the other
two angles the base angles in terms of
theta what would I have what would I
have them be let's call this o P Q how
would I find the size of angle o PQ how
would I do it any suggestions yeah
I'm gonna write it over here 180 minus
theta divided by 2 so that's our 90
takeaway feed on to does that check out
if this is 90 minus theta on to there
this should also be 90 minus theta on to
yes 90 minus theta on to but that means
that means that if I add up all of these
do I get the 180 that I'm after
does it work because the 90s will add up
to 180 the theater on twos and the theta
will cancel out does that look good all
right now
lastly onto this diagram if we know
these inside angles then what are these
outside angles over here what's their
size they're on a straight line the
tangent so you can figure out this two
ways you can think about this angle for
instance as the sum of the opposite
interior once you can do that
or just as easily because we already
have this angle you can think about
these guys as angles that add up to 180
degrees because what's the reason it
goes on a straight line okay so that
means what are they equal to this one
here 90 plus very good theta on to okay
now here's what I need you to imagine
take your pair of compasses you write
your paris is there right what I want
you to do is something weird something
that's not really the design of the pair
of compasses I want you to take your
pair of compasses and I actually want
you to put them not onto the page like I
used to but I want you to put them lay
it over the page on top of your Center
like this okay so I want you to imagine
the arms of your pair of compasses as
the arms of this angle Opie and OQ all
right
now I want you to picture what happens
if you take this guy and you start to
close the pair of compasses right now as
you close it what is happening to
theta it's getting smaller and smaller
and smaller at a certain point when
you've closed it what's Theta equal to
zero right but when you close the
compass right when you close the compass
do you notice what happens through this
triangle right this arm this this pair
of sides here need more colors this will
do as theta gets smaller and smaller
smaller for example you'll at some point
you'll get a triangle that looks like
this right so PQ is going to look like
that at a certain point if you keep
going you're going to get a really
really narrow triangle where P and Q are
even closer together when Theory zero
what happens to paint cute aren't they
both on exactly the same spot does that
make sense when theta is 0 with theta 0
P and Q the word we would use is they
coincide let's actually write that when
theta equals 0 P and Q Co in side
they're at the same place right we can
write this in another way and this is
language that you're again going to
encounter next year
something called a limit right we would
say as theta approaches 0 see that arrow
it means theta is going towards 0 P
approaches Q does that make sense let me
say it again
when theta approaches 0 P approaches Q
that makes sense and eventually they
land on top of one another okay well
when theta is 0 what happens to these
outside angles that we were looking at
before what happens to this guy when
theater is 0 it just becomes 90 it
becomes exactly 90 because look it's 90
Plus this thing which is becoming 0
right so that that angle there
corresponds to this angle over here do
you see it it's on the out it's the
exterior angle if you're trying to
except you don't have a triangle anymore
it's just a straight line of course
theta on 2 is 0 so that's why you have
the right angle that we were seeking to
prove does that make sense